If you're an audio buff
writing Android apps,
then there's some
exciting things
showing up in L
Developer Preview.
My name is Andy, and
today we're going
to talk about sample
rates for digital audio,
and how to give the best
sound to your users.
But hold on-- let's
start at the top,
and talk about
audio sample rates.
There's devices, content,
and connectivity.
And each one approaches
sample rates differently.
For example, this phone
has a device audio rate
of 48 kilohertz.
But that doesn't guarantee apps
on it will be using all of it.
Game apps often use 24 kilohertz
and 32 kilohertz sample rates.
Streaming music comes
in at 44.1 kilohertz.
Streaming video, 48 kilohertz.
Meanwhile, my
hands-free Bluetooth
is chugging along
at eight kilohertz.
Which means it's a jungle out
there with sample rates, even
just considering the smartphone.
So what is sample rate anyhow?
Simply put, given an
analog audio signal,
it's how often you
sample its waveform.
So when a game
uses 32 kilohertz,
we need to use a resampler to
convert to the 48 kilohertz
the phone needs.
As you can expect, this
process of resampling
can cause lots of issues.
Generally the one problem
everyone talks about
is aliasing.
Aliasing can occur when
the audio frequency
is too high for the sample rate.
Then the high frequency
signal looks like,
or aliases as a low
frequency signal--
as shown with the green
signal on the right.
The maximum audio
frequency without aliasing
is half the sample rate, also
called a Nyquist frequency.
In order to get rid of aliasing,
we use a low pass filter.
A low pass filter removes
the high frequencies,
which cause aliasing.
It has three bands.
The Passband is for
the audio frequencies.
The Stopband prevents high
frequencies from aliasing.
And the Transition
band is between them.
So what makes a good
resampler filter?
First, finite length.
With finite length,
ripples occur.
This is Gibbs' phenomena.
Second, we want the ripples
in the Passband to be small,
to avoid distorting our audio.
Third, we want ripples in
the Stopband to be small,
to avoid raising the Stopband,
and allowing high frequencies
to alias.
Last, we want to narrow
our Transition band.
A shorter filer length means
a wider Transition band.
It's related to the
uncertainty principal
between frequency and time.
You want a narrow
Transition band.
As you might imagine, designing
really good filters are hard.
Having the transition bandwidth
doubles the filter length,
doubling the stopband
attenuation doubles the filter
length.
Ugh-- design trade-offs.
Good news.
In Android, we compute the
sampler filters for you.
Check out these links for
information on how that works.
There's lots of
resamplers out there.
Where do the ones Android
audio provides fit in?
Like plants and animals, there
are polynomial resamplers
and filter resamplers.
On a polynomial
side, you've probably
heard of linear interpolators,
and cubic splines.
Those are typically
used for images.
We're a filter-based resampler.
This is more typical for audio.
In particular, we're using
a windowed sink filter.
Now let's talk
about Android audio
where we've improved
the resamplers.
We have increased quality.
In a spectrogram of a
sine sweep or chirp,
we inspect a single line.
This means one input
frequency corresponds
exactly one output frequency.
This should also be true
after sample rate conversion.
Our example shows 44.1
kilohertz to 48 kilohertz,
after a sample rate conversion.
Before we reach the top, see
that basket weave pattern?
That's aliasing in harmonics.
Bad.
After is the bottom,
which is much cleaner.
This at our low quality
setting, and means music
from many devices
will sound better.
We dynamically compute
filters for your frequencies.
In a spectrogram of 42
kilohertz to 32 kilohertz,
before we reach
the top, aliasing
is present on the
old resamplers,
as shown in the
reflected line down.
After is a bottom.
Again, we clean things up.
This is at our high
quality setting.
It means we have
less audio artifacts
at different frequencies.
We've also expanded the
frequency range for use
to any frequency between eight
kilohertz to 48 kilohertz.
So resampling we
can use for effects,
or reduce synthesis computation.
We've increased speed.
Our resample rates are
about twice as fast
as the older resamplers, for
comparable or better quality.
This means more processing
for other tasks,
and better battery lifetime.
We've made it easier
for you to use
the digital audio on Android.
We like it if you're liberated,
to use different sample rates.
Now, it's up to you to
make something great.
Please follow these links
for more information.
Thanks for watching.